hi I'm Eric Voss and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe may have found a
major game changer with an interesting
detail uncovered in the post-credits
scene of ant-man in the wasp youth you
were done with it didn't you
it's not wrong I'm gonna dig into what
you might have missed in the quantum
realm and how it could connect to of
interest Infinity Ward and Avengers for
spoiler warning in case I'm right okay
this detail has been making the rounds
but I think we could trace it back to
Reddit
let's rewatch the ant-man in the wasp
post-credit scene which was just
recently released on digital HD and
blu-ray which allows us to really look
at this footage frame by frame in super
detail by the way we're not insane for
doing this director Peyton Reed actually
said that he intentionally hid some
visual details in the background of the
quantum realm and we've already found a
whole quantum city so let's see what
else we can find okay so in this scene
Scott shrinks down into the quantum
realm with the help of Hank Hope and
Janet so that he can collect quantum
healing particles these are the things
that Janet used to help ghosts keep from
quantumly separating quantumly it's a
technical term scott enters a quantum
realm and collects some of these quantum
healing particles but he gets trapped in
this realm because this happens to go
down at the precise moment that oh snaps
his fingers and Hank Hope and Janet all
get caught in the dusting but here's the
detail at the redditor spotted shortly
before hopes transmission cuts out right
around the time she dusts away look at
the background of the quantum realm
behind Scott goes from a bluish purplish
color when it starts to fill with these
orange sparks starting around him with
fireflies now the rat theory is that
these sparks could be souls the souls of
the victims of Thanos's gusting we
speculated before that these snap
victims might not have died but rather
their souls were just transported to
another realm the moment Bannos did his
deed his consciousness was briefly
transported to another realm an orange
one which we later learned was inside
the orange soul stone and it contained
the soul of gomorrah the fact that these
sparks of the same orange color could be
a clue that maybe the souls of the dust
did get transported to the quantum realm
or perhaps a quantum realm is a
passageway a transitional state a river
styx or a purgatory whatever your belief
system is wherein the souls of Thanos's
rapture pass through like electrical
signals across nerve synapses that would
be a very interesting concept but if you
look even more closely at all this
footage
those orange sparks are definitely also
visible the moment Scott first arrives
in the realm
for the snap even hits so I think these
are just the quantum healing particles
that Scott was sent down there to
harvest and he could see a lot of that
orange globe the effects sucking into
the container when Scott opens it
perhaps after filling up on them the
nearby area was momentarily depleted and
then more quantum healing particles
spill over to fill that void kind of
like melted ice cream when you get a
good scoop that scrapes the bottom of
the cartons
yeah I finished a lot of cartons of ice
cream but that might pose an even more
interesting question what are quantum
healing particles like where do they
come from
with a nose snap his fingers half of all
life faded away but it's not like no one
was dying before that like across the
world right now nearly 105 humans die
every minute I know it's sad I'm gonna
be one of them soon with all the ice
cream cartons I finish and that's just
some planet Earth that's not a County
for all the others standard death rates
of other MCU planets that we know of
sand are sac are the sovereign contracts
iya the Kree homeworld of hala we're
talking thousands of living beings are
probably croaking every second and MCU
so what if these quantum healing
particles are actually souls souls of
everyday living beings after their
deaths re materializing on a subatomic
level and since there seem to be even
more orange sparks that flood the
background behind Scott after the snap
these could be the billions of new souls
that they have snapped out of existence
but that's the thing if you don't mind
getting me a physical for a second you
might not be able to snap a soul
completely out of existence there's that
idea that the human soul weighs 21 grams
because the human body supposedly loses
an unaccounted-for 21 grams at the
moment it expires in physics the law of
conservation of mass states that the
overall mass of a closed system must
remain constant and matter can never be
created or destroyed
so those 21 grams that got to go
somewhere and maybe instead of
transforming into Sean Penn movies these
21 grams of life matter break up into
particles that can be repurposed as
healing energy just kind of a beautiful
concept to consider right when you die
your soul breaks up into pieces and is
used to heal and prolong the lives of
others in need or put more bluntly
ant-man and his friends are using ghost
chunks to fix the Freak named ghost
so which quantum realm detail do you
think will be more critical to Avengers
4 these possible soul particles or they
possibly
quantum city comment down below with
your thoughts and follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at a boss and subscribe
the new rock stars for more explanations
of what an orange glow could mean by the
way that orange glow inside a
jack-o'-lantern
it's a pumpkins soul you can't chew on
that between those pieces of gross
orange taffy that the bad house hands
out happy Halloween